luciano bienvenido a france 24 y con
tres presidentes en el último año pero
ha dado muestras de una fuerte
inestabilidad política los dos
aspirantes aún en carrera obtuvieron
bajas votaciones en primera vuelta y
ahora están codo a codo en un empate
técnico de cara a la segunda vuelta que
pesará más el temor a las políticas de
izquierda que representa castillo o la
amplia impopularidad de fujimori
pues realmente es una votación que
estamos en la encrucijada una
encrucijada que en realidad vivimos hace
20 años después del retorno a la
democracia en la caída del gobierno de
fujimori lamentablemente lo que está
pasando es que creo que vale la
redundancia nos está pasando factura el
hecho de no haber realizado las reformas
políticas necesarias para que el país no
esté en una situación de zozobra en las
últimas segundas vueltas el resultado
como acaba usted de decir es
prácticamente un final de fotografía
estamos con un técnicamente un empate
vamos a ver hoy si es que esta noche el
debate entre los dos candidatos puede
generar prácticamente algún resquicio en
un espacio que pueda diferenciarse el
uno del otro porque según las encuestas
prácticamente estamos en un embate
técnico creo
y la campaña además ha sido una campaña
por un lado muy polarizada y por otro
lado creo que nada bien también ha sido
de que la mayoría de los medios de
comunicación se ha empleado a apoyar a
la candidatura de fujimori creo que eso
no ha sido lo más sano creo que después
del 6 de junio vamos a estar con una
mayor polarización cualquiera que sea el
ganador creo que definitivamente si el
perú no realiza las reformas políticas
estructurales que se necesitan la
próxima vez probablemente sea peor y con
unas candidaturas mucho más radicales de
las que hoy hemos tenido pero en el
corto plazo cuáles podrían ser los temas
que inclinen la balanza después del
debate de esta noche
creo que básicamente quien pueda generar
mayor confianza y eso es bastante
complicado porque estamos realmente
frente a dos candidaturas que como la
segunda vuelta lo que hace es aglutinar
votos porque no bien no se tienen más
alternativas probablemente lo que
sucederá es quien tenga si es que la
población pueda tener más confianza y
menos temor porque por un lado fujimori
representa el autoritarismo y la
dictadura de los 90 y lo que ha hecho la
señora fujimori cuando ha tenido el
poder en el último quinquenio traer el
parlamento y por otro lado es la fuerza
izquierda un tanto radical que
representa el señor castillo así que en
realidad es quien genere menos temor
quien pueda
más bien captar mayor confianza del
electorado eso es lo que creo que puede
inclinar la balanza y probablemente el
debate de esta noche puede servir para
ello bueno y hablando de cada cantidad
tokay que fujimori en un discurso
populista defiende que las
esterilizaciones forzadas en la época de
su padre fueron casi una leyenda una
política de planificación familiar
casos aislados de violación de derechos
este es un caso que reporta más de 270
mil víctimas le perdonará el electorado
ese desfase más aún siendo ella una
mujer
es algo muy difícil de aceptar realmente
creo que pueden keiko fujimori genera un
fuerte rechazo pero por eso es que
también lo que creo es que se ha
generado es una gran campaña de miedo
una gran campaña de miedo frente a lo
que puede significar un gobierno de
izquierda en tanto no solamente radical
por un lado por el líder fundador de
este partido de izquierda que lleva a la
segunda vuelta sino también por las
imprecisiones del equipo técnico que se
armado a último momento una postulación
del señor castillo bastante improvisada
pero lo que usted comenta de fujimori
muchos de nosotros no aceptamos una
posición de esa naturaleza por lo que
representa el fujimorismo el fujimorismo
representa la corrupción que representa
la dictadura es realmente una elección
trágica para muchos de nosotros los
peruanos que no estamos de acuerdo con
un sistema que lamentablemente vuelvo a
repetir no se ha reformado y que eso es
lo que genera lo que estamos en esta
inclusiva y muy cerca estaría el país de
poder elegir a la hija de un dictador y
está pedro castillo hacer lo mencionaba
un profesor de izquierda que sea
corto y cuya impopularidad ha ido
creciendo tras salir intempestivamente
del anonimato en primera vuelta
abandera la posibilidad de cambiar la
constitución o eliminar el congreso a
usted le parece que son contundentes
esas propuestas no para nada más hay
ejemplos icónicos en américa latina como
el caso de colombia con su reforma
constitucional del 90 que para nada una
asamblea constituyente inicial del resto
de poderes del estado o como por ejemplo
en la reciente reforma constitucional
que se está generando en chile que
tampoco va a disolver ningún poder del
estado esas son las cosas que generan
desconfianza por parte del señor
castillo porque necesitamos reformas
urgentes y claros de 20 años que las
necesitamos que no sean hechos
indudablemente las fuerzas políticas
controladores lo han impedido pero
definitivamente también hacerlo bajo un
programa bastante impreciso con un
equipo técnico que se llama último
momento
una postulación también bastante
improvisada es lo que genera también
cierta desconfianza en la ciudadanía por
eso decía creo que hoy en el debate
ojalá que se pueda generar una mayor
confianza y entonces los pocos indecisos
que existan puedan entonces inclinar la
balanza y ver qué cosa es lo que se
puede lograr en una elección ojalá
democrática esta noche